okay so yeah I was asked what my general
approach to Modern dating is uh and I
came up with this kind of this General
infrastructure it's generally how it
goes all right so obviously the Modern
Woman is generally a narcissist
generally like they're generally
addicted to energy attention and so the
first step is to ignore gusts like this
woman right so you ignore her because it
shows your high value and you guys like
her by by kind of alternating between
the alpha she wants and the beta
feminism tells her she wants right so
you've got to be a badass but also
emotional and kind of vulnerable but
also ignore this woman or she will lose
interest
in other words show desperation and then
completely yes 24 hours it's kind of
cool being a Coquette it's a bunch of
things but generally if you fail at
stimulating the modern woman's limited
attention span you lose so you have to
kind of flip between the alpha because
they want they all want the top guy but
they want that top guy to need them
that's being [__] so so you know if I
was if I was a six foot three athlete
with a six footer job why the [__] would
I want you like are you that special
you're not but I have to convince you
you are right
why do you have to convince us that we
are because [__] has infinite value
right you don't chase I chase you
because you're a queen you know that
anyway so Alpha Beta you Gaslight right
um You have to do at least these two and
flip between the alpha and beta step two
you get the contact details right so the
female has been uh properly stimulated
you're like uh you know let's Get Your
Number Instagram we'll hit you talk to
you whatever you have to keep this up
though step one never goes away
constantly you've got to do that when
you're married you've got to go to your
freaking coffin doing that right am I
gonna die who knows
that's sexy watch any movie the guy is
like I might pass away any time now he's
leaving notes and [__] this dude just
doesn't want to die he's just [__]
gaslighting her right so step two you
get the contacts and the emotionally
babysit so because of limited attention
she has she has these names right so by
emotionally babysitter I mean you've got
a kind of help her grow emotionally
she'd probably be hurt by some loser
um and you're gonna be one of those guys
but for now you've got to kind of soil
or trauma unpack all that stuff ask all
these cheesy questions no one really
cares about what was the last
relationship like do you value love uh
what kind of girl are you what kind of
guys she doesn't care what you like in
it so a lot of you guys in this stage
[__] up because you're telling us stuff
about you she doesn't care I've never
heard a woman be like I'm at this guy
and he's really interested in
architecture she doesn't care about it
doesn't care all she heard was your job
title and she saw how you looked in your
General Physics
that's it listen bro so you drive
exactly so you mostly babysit this
period takes one to three weeks because
obviously you know you can't answer too
frequently you've got to give a time you
know the gas lighting and the ignoring
is important got to make it feel like
you might ignore the text
um never reach too far you know make
statements don't ask questions or too
many questions and if you do ask a
question make sure it's something she
obviously wants to talk about like how
sexy she is her value in a long-term
relationship all that kind of [__] that
actually doesn't mean anything much she
probably tells herself that every night
so you do that one to three weeks has
passed now you're going for the kill
right invite her on maximum three days
this is my role you guys you Sims can do
100 if you want but I do three dates
date one cold close because you're still
gaslighting this [__] right how could
you let her know you kind of want to
shagger don't don't know that don't give
her that power she's gonna get gas so
you Gaslight her you know you're still
kind of flipping between Alpha Beta
second day you gotta close because you
know we all got jobs and stuff we've got
stuff to do right so we try and close if
that fails you go back to step one and
repeat if that succeeds I've got this
[__] right so now
what you do is it lasts for about four
weeks you know now you're kind of just
you know texting and hooking up
generally
um but you've got to tease long-term
relationship at some point because you
know she's going to convince herself if
you've made it this far she probably
could see herself with you right but
obviously I'm just here at the shark so
I'm just trying to you know I'm trying
to keep it going as long as possible so
it lasts about four weeks and then she's
kind of
I've noticed this kind of lines it links
up with the menstrual cycle the next
Marshall cycle she's gonna be like do I
need this guy man you know of everything
generally after about a month things
gonna get shaky you tease long-term
relationship oh you know
what do you want I'm not sure yet I know
what I [__] want I want a shag dude I
wanted a shark this whole time in a
month I'm gonna want a shag it doesn't
change
but you tease that yeah and you don't
have to do it too hard don't try too
hard just say stay less less is more
right because then she'll just you know
she'll figure out herself you know
she'll think what she wants to think and
then you repeat but generally you know
everyone has a shelf life she normally
kind of
the Smart Ones tend to kind of fade away
quicker
um but some of the Smart Ones last
longer those are the best but um
so when you end a relationship with the
modern woman because they're narcissist
you really don't want to give her any
ammunition because she will [__] about
you to everyone so all you've got to do
is you just go cold turkey you just stop
if you explain what she will tell people
is the things you just told her
explained which is going to be [__]
because we all just want to [__] so
she's gonna tell other people that and
then there's going to be rumors and
there's going to be all this energy I
don't want to give you that ammunition
so
I'll just go to yeah I'll just like just
why explain anything is she gonna listen
to you or not like hmm I get that I
wouldn't be with me either she's not so
what's the point is she gonna take your
critique absolutely not she's probably a
modern woman she can do it too he's
probably gonna tell you that like you're
some [__] you were abusive or
manipulative or or some kind of gas like
what kind of work that's like about
listen yeah let's do it it's modern
times
um so that's generally the
infrastructure
um it's a lot more complicated than this
class any questions I um I I have a
question yeah I have one too I have a
question first date right first date
right do you take us out with fancy
would you keep it cheap
listen this is a sister Mark and every
system
in this case it's this time which is
obviously everyone's limitation but it's
also moneybee it facts about four or
five [__] at the same time do you
think I made the money that's what I'm
saying I think I'm gonna take you out to
top restaurants thank you with no
guaranteed sucks are you dumb okay
you think you're that special so you'd
agree that if you're spend these
resources and time and energy then she
should be giving you six years you know
what I mean nothing is guaranteed
nothing is guaranteed in life which is
should but do you believe you should
listen it doesn't matter what I believe
I live I live by reality so this is
you're like listen I'm doing
it's kind of like job applications right
fire them out do you make one job
application and get all hyped up in your
little chair you make 10 job
applications you get three interviews
and then maybe you get one job offer
that's fine but the key thing is the
limitation the key limitation of this is
money and time and so the time
restrictions is seen here right three
days that's my general rule because I've
got a good job I've got all this stuff
going other [__] you know stuff like
that and the other key limitation is
money so you know I push it like trading
in it you don't want to invest more than
you're willing to lose yeah I'm not
willing to lose more than 25 pounds on
anyone right so wow listen you got the
first drink I got the first drink it's
like oh you know I'm being a gentleman
if you don't get this second drink
you're not getting anything else right
this has to alternate this has to
alternate I will I will give it to you
though I won't even leave it I'll just
be like you getting the next round and
if she doesn't I'll be like this [__] I
won't even keep it for four weeks if I
struggle they'll probably be two weeks
right
um so yeah that's that's the main about
this
any other questions class can I ask a
question what type of women do you
attract with this what type of woman do
you manage to trap in this cycle
um actually well I wouldn't say trap I
think they come if they're on a chord
but
generally my my main demographics are
early 20s University student highly
intelligent intelligence is my key
factor I can't do dumb girls so in other
words
dumb women are too chaotic for me and
it's just it doesn't fit my lifestyle
right you don't do any dumb hoes up in
here so they've all got to kind of know
you know what color this guy is that
kind of thing
early 20s and University graduates
they've gone to good Unis and they just
want to mess around and she knows what
she wants I don't have time to waste so
if you if you're kind of just figuring
out you can do that on someone else's
time I've got stuff to do the other
demographic is mid-30s and they've kind
of been around maybe it has some [__]
relationships they you know almost got
married whatever and now they're just
chilling these probably they're easier
to maintain as well because you know
they're 30 yards they manage themself
young guys want a lot of your time and
attention the older women are my
favorite because at this this current
time they're just as attractive as 22
years but they're more like independent
they can manage themselves less
stressful they'll even take you out did
I have kids thanks
um no I don't do anyone oh yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah second night yeah
so yeah generally is those two
occasionally I will trap a mid-20s girl
trap in a peak
well you know
but obviously it's because you know I
know it's not what's best for her and I
I avoid doing that I like I like to mess
with women who uh we can have fun and it
doesn't have any judgment on a long-term
relationship prospects you'll consider
it but I am I living myself
I treat Every Woman Like that's
someone's potential wife in it so I
wouldn't do anything with them that like
would make any other guy I have a good
reputation right that's because I work
very hard but you know this creates
trauma right I'm just gonna say like the
younger ones yeah it does create trauma
you know it's a cycle of no it's like
being a modern woman creates trauma you
already have trauma that's why you like
this thing no but relationship
a woman gets hurt by a man a man gets
hurt by a woman next you know everyone's
just out here just trying to be Savage
mode okay the worst thing about that
let's think about that okay yeah I'll
think about it and here's here's my
output right go ahead no one hurt you I
ghosted you no one did [__] you see
there's nothing I fell in love that's
how a business be that was you you
Charmed her come on
right that's that's how it is have you
been in love
um as
you know I was just banned on Tick Tock
and we are demonetized on a daily basis
on this platform if you want to help
please consider sending a super thanks
below every donation helps and it helps
make what we do possible